[Music]
we're here just outside of London out be
gfx now this company made every boy
walker every limb every dead body since
season four on Game of Thrones we've
been allowed to come into their
top-secret studio but spoiler alert if
you haven't seen some of the most recent
episodes you might want to look away now
[Music]
each FX is run by Emmy winners Sarah and
Barrett gawa who have worked in the
industry for over 20 years creating
prosthetics for Life of Pi
my cousin Rachel and a cure for wellness
I was working for various other
prosthetic designers and I was doing
little projects for makeup designers and
I was doing think that about a small
studio at home in our back garden I was
making bits and pieces then we had a
call and went for the interview for Game
of Thrones and that's running all sort
of kicks off for us really although we
first see the night king in season 4 in
brands vision it's not until the door in
season 6 that we see this version
performed by actor vladimir Ferdie the
whole process of making a head like this
is probably about maybe three weeks we
had a head cast in plaster Paris and
then we would sculpt the whole make up
as one in like a plasticine we would
make molds with fiberglass and epoxy
resin and then we would cast the
silicone appliances from them so it'd be
like basically a big jigsaw piece of
various bits and pieces every day that
the actor films he needs a brand new set
of appliances this makeup weighs about
two to three kilos and takes four hours
to apply but the night King was
originally planned to look a little
different we first sculpted home chess
piece which came down here because I
don't think the costume it'd be decided
on at the time as well and at one point
he's gonna be topless we see really been
awful at work probably doing all the
body art work
one of the most recognizable characters
is giant wooden actors who play the
Giants where silicone appliances while
standing in front of a green screen and
it's platinum base silicone which I
think it's originally created for the
medical industry when when you get it in
its raw state it's completely
translucent its water clear and then we
pigment it to whatever tone we need so
the soft in the piece the easier it
moves from the skin basically but I'd
like to wear one of these things that is
like putting your hands inside of a
plate of jelly all the pieces are really
cold so putting it on is a bit of a
shock but everything warms up to the
skin during the day how do you take off
it's not just white walkers stone men
and giants who need silicone masks the
process is also used on fat suits double
chins and chubby hands the show is
filled with various wounds and
infections like Jorah Mormont's
greyscale remember the scene in season 7
where Samwell Tarly removes all the
oozing scales one by one it was
effectively a lot of the same makeup but
we had a slightly different chest piece
which had a an under layer of raw skin
and then we had a patch which was pre
applied over the top but that was all
had this sort of integrated blood tubing
sort of leather at the bottom of his
piece and down his costume and there was
myself and Paul Spiteri behind him with
just blood tubes and pumps and it was
kind of on action which one is the
appealing way we had all this kind of
methylcellulose slime cut to me and Paul
behind him just pumping all this stuff
coming out of him on cue
turns out the team used another popular
TV show for inspiration we're all big
fans The Walking Dead here we're always
sort of scurrying online looking at what
they've been up to and what they're
doing but for us it was very important
that we want to do something quite
different as well turns out there's a
scale for how dead a weight looks well
we have super fresh whites which come
from Jane Walker's makeup department and
they are extras which is just like face
makeup and we'll have you paled down and
they put
bone structure a little bit of blood and
then our fresh whites have small cheek
bone appliances where we can sink the
eyes back a bit and we say oh they're
about six months old dead and then we
have sort of mid decomposed which are
heavier pieces top tip if you're using
fake blood on somebody don't use a wet
wipe to wipe it off because you'll stain
them orange next time you're watching
keep an eye on the whites this is a cast
of Michael birch who has played various
roles in wait for it 12 episodes
including that white that jumps out with
the crate troubled Cersei in season
seven he's played so many parts he's
been killed off so many times for battle
sequences such as battle the bastards
real-life extras and horses a mixed in
with loose fake limbs it's also these
limbs that are pinned to the wall in a
season a Episode one scene with Lord Ned
a birth thing it's like I mean the life
expectancy of these if you make a load
of props for a sequences it's rare
you'll get them back and they'll be in a
decent condition because they're usually
covered in so much blood and mud and
they're trampled on that's like my arm
hair that's just human hair what is this
made out of that's human hair so we
punch full heads of hair we do eyebrows
eyelashes and it's actually it's natural
hair which is sold and we buy in long
lengths and then the guys actually pre
curl it around small length of Dowling
and armed with that amount of hair on
will probably take about a day to punish
there are also entire trays of fake
wounds we have the frozen lake sequence
in season seven sixty to a hundred
whites on a day and just usually the
nature of just how nuts the filming
process is and how crazy the battles are
we rarely had continuity days where we
had to make sure this guy looked
identical each day because he was often
gonna be seen so we were able to just
make things up as we went from day to
day it's incredibly light and a bit like
jellyfish is yeah it's just like holding
it holding a jellyfish so what about all
of those dead bodies we see they're made
through a process called life casting
they will start with capturing a former
of the actors head or body and we'll use
silicon lifecasting material and plaster
bandage so you see people with casts on
their arms with the plaster bandage and
we use that as our - shell and then
effectively we have a mold of their head
which we can then pour in plaster of
Paris to get a positive copy of the head
these are all that so I wrote rogue's
gallery of Game of Thrones sort of over
the years it's at Joffrey it's obviously
he stops you know bleeding out his eyes
and it goes the color of radish so that
was a bit of a collaboration between
Jane Walker and her team doing his
makeup on the day and then it was visual
effects as well there's quite a lot in
post sort of making his eyes a little
bit off
we should probably qualify that the Aria
head was made for her Walder Frey mask
and the Hal came here for his makeup
tests but which now adult-sized heads
are underneath Lee's bin bags we're not
allowed to see them yet ageing is also a
process that his use of various
characters remember that oh my god
moment when Melisandre takes off her
necklace in a season six premiere we use
a lot of reference
I mean old-age makeups is something is
quite common in the prosthetic sort of
world so we've got so many books and
books so many files were downloaded
elderly sort of skin and textures and
what have you we did a very exaggerated
kind of sculpture and it was
accentuating the nose or the bone
structure and what-have-you and then we
had to thin her hair so she had a
complete silicon bald cap and then she
had a double who really sweet elderly
lady
I think came with Sheila and she we shot
performance with her as well walking
from the bed they shot her first and
then Carice sort of matched her
movements as well and visual effects
kind of tied the two together
that's all we have time for our favorite
bit probably the realistic limbs made
with human hair we won't be forgetting
that anytime soon